die welt schaute derzeit auf glasgow wo
es darum geht sie zu retten
weltklimakonferenz mit viel nicht nur
politprominenz gestern abend nach der
eröffnung wir schauen mal auf ein paar
bilder kate und william waren da prinz
charles war da die bilder müssten gleich
kommen der sich ja immer schon für
umweltschutz eingesetzt hat die queen
konnte aus gesundheitlichen gründen
nicht dabei sein hat sich aber mit einem
eindringlichen video appell an die
gemeinschaft gewendet jetzt zu handeln
und da sehen wir joe biden den
amerikanischen präsidenten während er
ein kleines nickerchen gemacht hat bevor
er dann zum rednerpult gegangen ist
vielleicht liegt es auch daran dass er
ein jetlag hatte denn er ist erst am
montag gestern also zu diesem klima
gipfel angereist und damit sind wir dann
auch beim thema denn
25.000 teilnehmer aus 197 nationen sind
auch aus deutschland in das schottische
glasgow gerais viele im privatjet um die
erderwärmung zu stoppen und dabei
verursachten sie einen co2 ausstoß von
schätzungsweise mehr als
13.000 tonnen das ist wahnsinn im studio
ist philippiak und sein bild in meinem
chef ich glaube wir können noch mal kurz
auf die bilder schauen dazu
hier kommen die klimaretter na ja wo er
die öko heuchler denn die staatschefs
könig und milliardäre dieser welt die
reise natürlich nicht fürs klang zum
klimagipfel an nein sie kommen mit
privatjet
amazon chef bezos einer der reichsten
menschen überhaupt predigt gerne mal
umweltschutz landet aber selbst im 55
millionen euro
prinz albert von monaco dir kommt
natürlich auch im privatjet und für die
königsfamilie von abu dhabi und reicht
selbst darf nicht mehr die rollen also
einfach nur eine eigene boeing 737
allein am sonntag landeten 52 privat
jets mit vermeintlichen klima ändern in
glasgow umgerechnet sind das mindestens
13.000 tonnen kohlendioxid die co2
bilanz von 1500 deutschen co
chairman und weil diese bands natürlich
auch irgendwann wurde der flughafen
schnell zu klein so dass manche sogar
eine noch mal abheben muss 51 kilometer
weiter abgestellt
das geht definitiv an
[Musik]
jetzt aber da philipp potthoff unser
bild meinung chef guten morgen findet
das ist doch wieder mal doppelmoral vom
feinsten oder absolut ich habe hier auch
schon unsere bild zeitung von heute
mitgebracht hier mit der schlagzeile im
privatjet zum klimagipfel ich glaube das
sagt alles bei diesen klimagipfeln geht
es ja vor allem um symbolik wird zur
richtigen ergebnissen rechnet niemand
völlig zurecht china ist nicht da
russland ist nicht da also mit die
größten co2 emittenten die hatten
überhaupt keine lust dahin zu fliegen da
trifft sich also ein großteil der
westlichen welt aber auch viele andere
länder und wollen ja schon irgendwie
signalisieren jetzt müssen wir uns
zusammenraufen und jetzt müssen wir
anfangen mehr für das klima zu tun
wirklich dafür zu kämpfen es ist noch
ein bisschen schwierig wenn die alle mit
ihren privatjets kommen und auch die
ganzen moralaposteln die ceos die
sogenannten grünen cios wie jeff bezos
der amazon gründer zum beispiel der
wirklich seit jahren auch für
klimaschutz predigt auch wenn der mit
seinem privatjet kommt und woher kommt
er von einer privaten geburtstagsparty
von bill gates die in der nähe der
türkischen
auf einer mega yacht stattfand ja also
eine megajacht auf der die gäste auch
natürlich per helikopter eingeflogen
wurden anders kann man als klimaretter
offenbar nicht feiern also wenn man von
diesem gipfel irgendwie ein zeichen
ausgehen soll für die normalen menschen
dass die sich zusammenreißen sollen dass
sie sich vielleicht weniger ins ausland
weniger in den urlaub fliegen sollen
weniger auto fahren sollen da kann man
sich noch fragen also wollten wir uns
eigentlich veralbern er soll daran
glauben ich glaube man muss darauf
hinweisen dass es uns um den privatjet
geht es ist eine insel großbritannien
also man kann nicht hin schwimmen oder
mit dem katamaran fahren wie württemberg
vor zwei jahren über den atlantik dh die
25.000 teilnehmer müssen da irgendwie
hin kommen absolut also ich meine ganz
viele menschen haben jetzt in der korona
pandemie gelernt dass man auch per zoom
konfigurieren kann person sich
versammeln kann das hätte man ja
versuchen müssen aber den staats und
regierungschefs nehme ich das auch gar
nicht so richtig übel wobei auch da
natürlich ist alles eine frage der
symbolik ist und wenn man sich nunmal
trifft um den um das klima zu retten
dann stellt sich die frage welches
zeichen geht davon aus wenn man ein
veganer gipfel stattfinden lässt und
dort tolle schlachtplatte serviert
werden kann man danach auch nicht sagen
na ja die leute hatten halt hunger also
politik ist eine frage der symbolik und
welche leute wie jeff bezos und viele
andere stars und gründer eingeladen
werden die aber erst mal von ihrer
welttournee mit dem privatjet angeflogen
kommen da kann sich ja normal menschen
fragen was wollt ihr uns damit
eigentlich sagen ein vorschlag zur güte
vielleicht man könnte sich ja auch so
ein jet teilen na ja man könnte sagen
gut gesammelt vielleicht mal hier und da
den anderen denn ein oder anderen ein
und fliegt dann zusammen das wäre schon
mal zeichnen die richtig gesucht genau
so ein richtig schönes privatjet
sammeltaxi um zu zeigen auch die
staatschefs auch dies noch die ganzen
milliardäre können sich zusammenreißen
man muss auch dazu sagen dass es
natürlich auch sinn machen kann sich vor
ort zu treffen und nicht nur per video
weil sich natürlich eine andere dynamik
entwickelt auch ein druck entwickelt
wenn man nächtelang zusammensitzt wir
haben ja auch bei den
ministerpräsidenten konferenzen zu
gewohnter gesehen die laufen ganz anders
wenn sie für video laufen daddeln an
welche unterm schreibtisch rum sie geben
halt eher an die presse wertvolle
informationen weiter auch das gehört ja
dazu
ich muss sagen ich weiß jetzt nicht auch
was bei dem klimagipfel herauskommen
wird klimagipfel haben sich vor allem
dadurch von allen anderen gipfel
unterschieden dass am ende kein ergebnis
stand mit dem irgendjemand zufrieden zum
stichwort wälder gibt es ja eine
ergebnis bis 2030 soll die rodung
zurückgefahren werden drastisch sind
allerdings auch noch zehn jahre in denen
weiter geholzt werden kann also wenn das
darauf sich die länder einigen einigen
können die da sind ist das schön und gut
ich glaube bei ganz vielen ländern wie
indien china wie russland wie brasilien
nicht unbedingt daran dass sie sich
daran halten werden und das sind die
länder auf die es ankommt die haben sich
dazu verpflichtet sind in der gruppe
allerdings beklagt frage ist ob es
tatsächlich dann umsetzen